[Music]
our culture is having a nostalgic moment
whether it's the remakes and reboots of
classic hits the reborn love of things
from the 80s and 90s lo-fi chill hump
nostalgia is in stranger things is a
show that both represents and
capitalizes on that nostalgia the
electronic music genre vaporwave is
another image of this collective
nostalgia so how do these two different
media overlap thematically and will that
overlap tell us anything about why
nostalgia is so big right now this video
is sponsored by 8 hours go to 8 hours
calm to find a curated list of video
essays like this one that you can browse
by director topic and genre vaporwave is
easier to show you than it is to explain
genre of electronic music that has
developed over the last decade and has
its roots and techniques as banal and
simple as slowing down existing songs it
often relies on Spacey since and layered
effects that create a sense of nostalgia
longing and wistful memory often
specifically for the 80's and 90's born
out of chillwave genre obsessed with 80
cents in vaporwave is based around
repurposing sounds and samples from the
80s and 90s and placing them within a
nostalgic context sometimes literally
decaying the sounds and images creating
an effect where it often feels like
you've come across an old worn-out copy
of an 80s song vaporwave has spawned
subgenres like simpson wave placing
slightly old media within a nostalgic
frame but one unique small sub-genre of
vaporwave makes the connection to
stranger things that I want to highlight
here most obvious small soft small soft
as a subset of vaporwave involves music
that sounds like it's being played in an
often empty mall this music evokes
nostalgia for a bygone consumerist
utopia an era of bustling malls color
and abundance
[Music]
stranger thinks three capitalizes on a
nostalgia for the same era both capture
a distinct feeling of the colorful
vibrant consumerism that the mall embody
a sort of limitless luxury for all in
excess free from concerns about
environmentalism ethical manufacturing
labor or late capitalism there's a key
difference in the perspective each of
these take on this era vaporwave and
mall soft positioned themselves in our
present looking back in a mournful
wistful way giving the empty dying mall
center stage one thing that illustrates
this is Dan Bell's dead mall series on
YouTube which involves tours of dying
malls across America while you can hear
in the background the real-life
equivalent of what mall soft attempts to
replicate paper waves connection to the
dying mall can also be seen in the
YouTube mashup videos that combine old
footage of malls with vaporwave music
playlists stranger things season 3 on
the other hand focuses on the burgeoning
of this era of the glory of the mall
still in its present tense
[Music]
there are no empty abandoned malls yet
in the world of stranger things
but while stranger things openly
glorifies them all and this sort of
brazen consumerism do you like that how
do I know I like you just try things on
until you find something that feels like
you like me yeah
not hopper not mic
you it also has its concerns about
runaway capitalism and it holds these
ideas in competition my main point here
is that both carry attention between
glorifying and reminiscing about the era
of the mall while portraying an
underlying skepticism and concern
vaporwave through its future perspective
of decay and loss and stranger things by
making the same mall a battleground with
monsters and bad guys lurking in the
darkness and beneath the surface
vaporwave preceded stranger things and
while it's possible that it influenced
stranger things directly I think it's
more likely that these themes arose
independently of each other out of the
same cultural foundation both of
reminisce about a kind of hope one that
culture as a whole doesn't feel very
often anymore a time when naivete meant
the materialism of the mall could be
enjoyed guilt-free when capitalism was
about to usher us into a technological
utopia
so what do you think
things were developing fast the internet
and cell phones were on the horizon and
we couldn't get see the downsides of
these developments how our privacy would
erode and the distractions and problems
smartphones and social media would bring
with them
[Music]
[Music]
outrun another genre of music to spawn
from chillwave and a sort of cousin of
vaporwave presents the nostalgic synths
of the 80s but with a darker and more
aggressive tone outruns visual and
Sonic's similarity to stranger things is
another notable link in this somatic web
of nostalgia I think all of these things
arise out of a specific cultural feeling
there may because the creators feel a
certain way and they resonate because
audiences feel a certain way about the
past and where we are now whether or not
these scenes are true is irrelevant for
them to be relevant and engaging they
merely need to connect with current
perceptions strangest things in
vaporwave don't have to be accurate
representations of the past in fact many
of the young people who watch the show
and listen the vaporwave myself included
weren't even alive in the 80s so its
accuracy isn't important it's a
nostalgia for a past we imagine
existence but why long for the past why
be enticed by a lost hope when
Millennials and younger generations look
around at society and don't see hope for
the future seeing technology and
consumerism not about to usher us into
the next great era but as something that
preys on our attention destroys our
planet that might create AI monsters
it's hard to find a hope in that future
so we might cling to or reminisce about
and a hope that existed in the past or
at least one we imagined did we might
even collectively mourn a lost innocence
and glory that the mall represented and
if that's what we want and that's how
feel stranger things and vaporwave are
there to feed that nostalgic longing for
that hope thanks so much - eight hours
for sponsoring this video recently they
started producing original video essays
in this video director David Lowry
explains the choices he made in a scene
from his film the old man and the gun
you can watch this video essay and
others now at eight hours dot-com eight
hours is a website where you can browse
video essays from all over the internet
if you love video essays eight hours is
an essential resource they help you find
video essays like mine and make it
really easy to browse for them by
director filmmaking technique genre or
creator if you're a fan of video essays
you've really got no excuse not to check
it out that's the number eight hours
comm thank you so much for watching this
video a special thank you to my patreon
supporters you can go to
patreon.com/scishow
how you can support my channel on an
ongoing basis and get access to things
like my monthly podcast and monthly
bonus video